Speaker 1: One of the big questions
about the 2022 midterm elections has been
as we get past the primaries, what do the
general elections look like? Pennsylvania is
a great example. In Pennsylvania, we had very
prominent primaries for the governor's race.
This guy, Doug Mastriano, who is essentially a big
lie, January 6th rioter. That's essentially what
he is. Doug Mastriano won the Republican primary
for governor in Pennsylvania and will now face
Josh SHAPIRO. But the question is, well, how is
that race looking in the Republican Senate race?
Mehmet Oz was endorsed by Trump, won ultimately
won a very, very close primary. But the question
is, how is Oz faring against John Fetterman, the
overwhelming victor in the Democratic primary
for the Pennsylvania Senate? What does it look
like for November? We finally have those numbers
and it really depends on whether you want to be
a glass half full or a glass half empty sort of
person. When it comes to these polls, whether
we say that it's looking good or that it's
not looking good. So let's look at the polls,
which we've been waiting for for a long time.
The Post-Gazette reports Democrats John Fetterman
and Josh SHAPIRO lead Republicans Mehmet Oz and
Doug Mastriano in the first big Pennsylvania
general election poll. Okay, that's good.
The Democrats are winning for the general
election. Well, but how much? Well, this is
where it's maybe not quite so good in the Senate
contest. Democratic candidate John Fetterman,
Pennsylvania sitting lieutenant governor,
is up by nine over Republican Mehmet Oz,
the celebrity cardiothoracic surgeon. That's 46
to 37, with 13% of respondents undecided. Okay.
That's the Senate race. In the race for governor,
Democrat Josh SHAPIRO, the state attorney general,
leads Republican Doug Mastriano, a state
senator by a slimmer margin by 444 to 40,
with 13% of respondents again declaring themselves
undecided. Okay. So we have the numbers.
Are these numbers good or are these numbers bad? I
can genuinely make two completely different cases
to you about this. Let me make to you the most
optimistic case. The Republican primaries got
way more attention than the Democratic primaries.
Josh SHAPIRO was unopposed. John Fetterman was
expected to easily win, and he did. Despite all
of the attention on the Republican primaries,
the Democrats are still winning. Josh SHAPIRO is
arguably much less well-known than Doug Mastriano.
He didn't have any kind of like major endorsement
that I'm aware of, like Mastriano had Trump's and
despite all of that, all of that attention, all
of the name recognition, the Democrats are still
winning and they're winning both races.
Great, though. Okay. But wow. David, sir,
thank you for the optimistic case. Now, what's
the pessimistic case? Well, the pessimistic case
is Fetterman is winning by nine, but
there's 13% undecided. And Pennsylvania is,
although it has typically typically leaned blue
to the left, it doesn't always and 13% undecided
is not particularly good and 9% is not a
comfortable lead there. And then when you look at
the gubernatorial race, you can make an even
more pessimistic case, which is, wait a second.
Despite the fact that Mastriano is quite literally
a rioter in the sense that he allegedly passed and
breached police barricades in D.C. on January
six. Despite that, he's only losing by four
with 13% undecided. That's a disaster because the
general campaigns are only just starting. This is
really not good. Now, which of the two cases do I
lean towards? Eileen Slightly to the pessimistic
case. We have a situation in the United States
right now where Mastriano was a participant at
the insurrection. He spent over $3,000 to bus
over 100 Trump supporters to D.C. On January 6th,
he was seen crossing police barricades despite
denying it. And even despite all of that, he's
only losing by four. And 13% are still undecided
because we are in an era where these things are
no longer disqualifying. Think of the Hollywood
acts, the Access Hollywood tape with Donald Trump
in the past that would have ended many elected
officials or potential elected officials careers.
And Trump went on to become president of the
United States and almost to get himself reelected.
So is it better that the two Democrats in
Pennsylvania are winning rather than losing?
Of course it's better. They were losing. It would
be an. Even bigger disaster. But these leads,
particularly the Mastriano lead, the battery,
the Josh SHAPIRO lead over Mastriano rather.
These are not comfortable leads in any sense. So
when we think about where is there a race that we
can really kind of make a difference, and we've
talked about this whole Marcus Flowers versus
Marjorie Taylor GREENE thing. Marcus Flowers is a
fine candidate against Marjorie Taylor GREENE in
Georgia, but as many people have written in. It's
not really likely that being such a red district
pouring money in for Marcus Flowers or phone
banking is going to remove Marjorie Taylor
GREENE. And I never say give up on a race,
but it is statistically true that that's a big
uphill battle. If efforts were concentrated
on the really important races, this one in
Pennsylvania could be huge because number one,
Fetterman versus Oz could decide who controls the
Senate for the next two years, and the governor
of Pennsylvania could decide who wins Pennsylvania
in 2024. The real winner or whoever Doug Mastriano
wants to see. These are really consequential
races. Does it not make more sense to put our
efforts there? It's a question that we're going
to have to figure out as we get closer to November
and then into 2024. Let me know what you think.
Find me on Twitter at DH Pacman. But at least
they're not losing. That's what we can say so far.
The David Pakman Show is an audience supported
independent media program. I would love
for you to sign up on my website. Join
Pacman dot com. We do an extra show every
day for our website subscribers and you
can use the coupon code. Big Voting 22 to
get yourself a discount off of the cost
of a membership at Join Packman Kcom.